bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa vj oggi sto cazzo
di cava e oggi i ragazzi sono tornati su
su motori dreams che non facevo da non
mi ricordo neanche più se ero nato
quando l'ho fatto ultima volta facendo
veloce giusto per per chi non lo
conoscesse c'è alla presente su motori
dreams è un gioco serio ragazzi come
gesù come cazzo sono rimasto un po che
va dai ragazzi vince chi rimane in piedi
per ultimo sta cosa è fantastica ogni
cosa ho vinto una volta cominciamo mai
adesso vinco sempre uno sa perché la
propaggine togliti la mio pene lurido il
mio culo
ecco bravo non hanno scusa scusate eh
vabbè mi mancava ma da morire sui motori
dismisura
era da secoli che valori giocata niente
poi il bello che fa che cazzo fa ragazzi
no ma cosa sto facendo
ma perché ma perché ma di certo ragazzi
partiamo con la prossima non perché
allora mi stavo divertendo
abbiate pazienza quando mi dimetto mi
girano le balle voglio fare sempre
quello tra ghana che posso fare per un
video lo stesso livello allora questo
non so se ve lo ricordate ragazzi io
purtroppo me lo ricordo tanto sta
facendo il verde suo livello è veramente
particolare per chi non lo conoscesse è
giusto perché allora vi faccio vedere un
attimo perché limite cade una roba ne
sono morto
io sono il suono morton e possibile
alzati e maledicendo che è perché sto
saltando come un grillo sembro io la
mattina quando devo andare a scuola che
mi devo alzare dal letto e così buttati
in mezzo in volta è bravo così bravo
perfetto pam madonna
[Musica]
forse è successo regala non è possibile
no non ho ben fermo blu fermato la vita
è bella la vita è bella non puoi fare lo
abbiamo perso la gara l'abbia cosa fai
ma come sono caduto di culo tra l'altro
spesso sono morto cosa infierisce tutt
stronzo avete visto che un gioco serio
no io mi piace fare queste cose ma non
l'ho preso cazzo 1 bicas lo prendevo
buttarlo devo buttare giù tutta la vita
tipo guarda lo guarda lo guarda si no
non è caduto tu non puoi bastare sono
morto io dai minchia cadi cioè perché io
me la prendo con i più deboli perché
credo che il bianco rimarrà lì per tutta
la vita quindi e vi faccio l'ultima in
questo livello perché bellissima
comunque il verde ha prima fatto una
partenza detonato tipo anche adesso è il
verde deve morire così ragazze è fatto
così guardatelo e fucile guardaroba è
morto poi la gente mi dice ma parco
giochi a un videogame dove la dove ci
sono i lottatori di sumo ubriachi c'è ma
mi fate anche queste domande come
possono giocare a questo capolavoro che
sto facendo
cos'è rimasti in casa nokia ci ha messo
un braccio nella mia tavola ascolta il
mio verde lo so che tu sei un sì ci dava
non siccome ero lo sapevo se sei
deficiente nel cervello è normale fermi
tutti
ragazzi è un razzo lui lavora per la
nasa miglia che botta terminati niente
sono caduto io come un deficiente su un
paletto
se ti togli dal mio culo mi fa un
piacere anno annuncia mi pure la chiappa
sinistra zio però non è che è bravo devo
capire un attimo visto il gioco come non
mi ricordo più senza svenire non riesco
a fare due fottuti passi ma si può già
farlo sto facendo coming o no no no no
mi cadere così li mortacci sua guarda di
cosa c'è di stato livello è piena di
significato comunque complimenti però se
non a cimice proprio con questa ragazza
che da un botto che non è il colonnello
tassi mica me la ricordo questa perla
ragazzi sono ci sono solo show ma
[ __ ] proprio che non è non è così
sono caduto subito niente niente l'ha
messo di fatto ultimo ma si può come
faccia arrivare poi due in cado per
ultimo però gli altri cadono prima ong
bak e botta sul gruppo amag lo sono io
ami sondato la botta alla sola perfetta
ma perché è possibile che cadeau per
primo ho visto cose fare in questo gioco
guarda che sito è la madonna che spinta
prendo la mia sentita
c'è stato un terremoto forse madonna
madonna madonna niente il vero il verde
deve starmi proprio sul culo ma ne
proprio in quel senso qualche roba mi ha
scocciato ragazzi fa vj sepolto vivo è
finita così pazienti sincro e poi due si
ingrossano ma si può
nei secoli che io gioca ai videogame si
non ho mai visto un gioco più bello di
queste 6 rimane primo in classifica
primo sempre piacere di giocare a certe
cose comunque ragazzi è bellissimo ha
già questo non ricordo anche tutti
quanti sulle mani
siamo morti tutti ma sono il verbo è
caduto ci siamo però ci siamo
bravo marrone vai giù bravo così come un
deficiente di pronti al salto ma niente
cos'era sta roba cosa non nuti e che ti
guardi i piedi
ragazzi ma si è drogato smettete di fare
i porci niente ma guarda il bianco che
fa stretching piuttosto poi c'è il buona
lena cosa saggia ha già ok mi sono
ricordato la ascolta inizio io io non
sono un tuo nemico
tu non sei mio nemico non mi toccare
rappresenta più o meno il mio ultimo
compito di matematica una merda comunque
preferisco arcese io sono rimasto
schiacciato da una giustamente da una
tavola che continua a niente continua
rimarrò così nei secoli vuoi rimanere
per ultimo in piedi sta cosa impossibile
perché non si può rimanere in piedi in
sto livello si provoca minati maga magò
andrà come lo dribla come la tripla di
cadere tutti di cadere tutti ricadere
tutte ricadere tuo io sono salvo dove di
questo lo vendi con lo vedi dove sono io
per la rivoluzione
cosa ho fatto riuscita a salvarmi in una
maniera che cos'è sta roba
ragazzi siamo siamo mica che testata ce
la posso fare alzate a non sfasciare
tutto alzati per niente sul nostro così
deve vedermi soffrire proprio eccomi
possono bastardo vieni qui vieni qui io
io a me piaceva questo palo ecco bravo
prenditela colpa lo sta facendo lo di
preciso niente cia col palo e cado io
cosa chiedo io che sono in piedi da solo
con ragazzi si chiama si chiama templi
io ho paura vedere cos'è c'è una c'è un
cubo blu nome ai corsi fermi fermi
la madonna che cazzo è successo alberti
è la madonna il marrone ragazzi è morto
è rimasto a metà è una cosa sono rimasto
io ho vinto
[Musica]
no regista mappa ragazzi non l'ho capita
non l'ho capita la li faccio un anno
giura veramente non ho capito nulla
ecco espressa roba esplodere è ancora
finito a sky
poi è crollato il mondo a caso capitoli
a sei stupido
[Musica]
io avevo voglia di fare paracadutismo
senza paracadute ogni tanto mi sveglio
ciò se idee miu miu e vabbè ci ho
provato
cosa che la madonna marrone
[Musica]
caduta dall'alto ragazzi questo ecco
infatti posso si può spingere la madonna
che partenza è stato bello complimenti
che fanno sono morti tutti
no no marrone no ma perché è stato fatto
io sto diventa si chiama meteora
ecco perfetto aggiudicato il terreno
dove devo aver paura però non ne sono
sicuro lurido ma che è successo ma la
madonna
se andiamo pure fa vj nell'iperspazio
inca la barca va lasciala mi ha dato che
è successo e mi hai mai volato il
marrone no rimasto schiacciato
vabbè dai secondo me si è fatto ma non
ancora incastrato com'e ormai non mi
dico non mi ricordo pr sta roba ajami
che era due anni fa l'ultima volta che
ho fatto store in realtà è che chiusa
ecco cos'è sono vivo cosa fai verde cosa
fa il verde il cui unito era roba
pazzesca
niente sono jean pato e da solo cioè
fatemelo riprovare permettedo stare
fermo per vincere perché basta ecco io
sono in piedi per ultimo bello
complimenti suplex affinché botta ma
perché siamo tutti sotto la cosa che sta
per crollare
non possiamo andare a giocare nel parco
qualcosa di tutti bravi complimenti che
cazzo fai bianconi è rimasto lì stavolta
ci prova ragazzi a bomba
complimenti per la morte plica di
wrestling se il mio nuovo mito sera
l'ultima volta raga poi basta perché non
è possibile si madonna che facciata o
dato notizia
d'accordo ragazzi forse io sono caduto
in partenza si vede proprio la partenza
di chi è capace è un domino questo
ragazzi bellissimo
tranne il fatto che io continuo a non
stare in piedi porca vacca walker
incredibile stanno cadendo dei pezzi di
domino dal cielo non è normale comunque
se ci becca uno di quei cosi tu lo sai
che siamo morti il marrone si è salvato
per miracolo tipo ragazzi che cazzo sta
succedendo laggiù oh mio dio è arrivato
è arrivato una tavola pazzesca a tutta
velocità però sono vivo con i ragazzi
sono i piedi non ci posso credere
assurdo che è successo è esploso tutto
da un momento all'altro mi fa piacere
sta cosa no dai togliete dalle balle per
favore mi fate stare tra la gente deve
strutturare me perché questo può dare
qualcosa giusto che giaquinto che sono
incazzato ti puoi per favore togliere
dal cap
sì che ho preso una tavola perfetto già
beccati pieno una tavola fanta vedi che
ti dovevi togliere alle palle rimasta
anche incastrato al verde bellissimo è
chiaro ragazzi concludo qui perché mio
dio è sempre bello rigiocarci vi servono
chiedevate in tanti lo fatto comunque
ragazzi se qualcuno di voi sa che cosa
hanno bevuto di preciso la notte prima
di di fare sta roba mi fa piacere perché
voglio capire il disagio da dove
arrivare qualcun altro mi deve spiegare
perché ci sono le tavole che volano in
sa cosa ancora non l'ho capita prova
bene a parte la lenti finale che spacca
il brutto dire che possa concludere qui
vi ragazzi come al solito sei video
piaciuto fare mi fa la partenza solo poi
si stupra una vicenda e va bene così ok
perfetto sei video è piaciuto ragazzi
come al solito sotto commento mi piace
anche a farseli facebook e come non i
video top vestizione centristi dissi
mentre ci vediamo al prossimo video
bello ragazzi